- So Hensler declares that,
"The marriage has become
very unsupportable,
unless she consents to having
her mouth surgically closed."
My God, man.
Holy cow, you put this
in front of the court.
A pleading is a document
that you file with the court.
And whenever I file a pleading,
it is well-researched,
it makes good faith,
well-reasoned arguments,
and it is spell checked
within an inch of its life.
But the pleadings we're
talking about today
have none of those things.
These are the most bizarre
and ridiculous pleadings
that have ever been filed
in an American court.
We start with the Iowa man
who requested trial by combat.
So in America, we take
pride in a judicial system
that allows anyone to have
their grievances heard
before a neutral judge
or a jury of their peers.
And instead of resolving
disagreements through duals,
like "The Days of Yore,"
legal disputes can be addressed
in a calm and civil manner.
Well, that is the ideal, at least.
Because reality is often
much, much different.
Enter David Ostrom of Paola, Kansas,
who during a heated custody
battle against his ex-wife,
requested an Iowa court
turn their legal battle
into a literal battle,
complete with samurai swords.
In an effort to resolve a dispute
over his ability to communicate
with his two children
and get his ex-wife to pay property taxes
on their former home,
Mr. Ostrom filed a motion challenging
his former spouse and her attorney
to quote "trial by combat."
Mr. Ostrom was purportedly
inspired by Richard Luthmann,
a Staten Island attorney and
"Game of Thrones" officinato,
who requested a trial by combat
to settle a dispute with
another lawyer and his clients.
In Mr. Ostrom's motion he wrote,
"My ex-wife and her attorney indicated
they have destroyed me legally,
now I wish to give them the chance
to meet me on the field of battle,
where I will rend their
souls from their bodies."
Mr. Ostrom, ever the chivalrous type,
said his ex-wife's
attorney would be allowed
to fight in her place as
her, quote "champion."
Mr. Ostrom defended the
legality of this request
before the court by writing quote,
"Trial by combat was still regarded
as a legitimate method
for dispute resolution
when the constitution was
ratified in the United States
by the original 13 colonies.
To this day, trial by combat
has never explicitly been
banned or restricted as a right
in these United States."
Check mate. Never rescinded. Still okay.
That's how the law works, right?
So Mr. Ostrom also requested
a three month delay
so he could obtain two
samurai swords for the fight.
In opposition to Mr.
Ostrom's medieval motion,
the counsel for Ostrom's ex-wife,
who refers to himself in
the response as quote,
"potential combatant," very cheeky,
that is a excellent
defining term, argued quote,
"Although the respondent
and potential combatant
do have souls to be rended,
they respectfully request that the court
not order this done.
We humbly request that the
court deny this motion,
as the potentially life
ending ramifications
surely outweigh the severity
of the petitioner's proposed legal remedy
of trying to avoid
responsibility for property taxes
and to acquire additional
telephonic communication.
What a buzzkill, seriously.
Now I regret to inform you that the judge
denied Mr. Ostrom's motion,
while granting opposing counsel's request
to temporarily suspend Mr.
Ostrom's child visitation rights
and order a psychological evaluation.
Like a guy can't just request
trial by combat to the death?
I mean, judges.
Mr. Ostrom was declared sane
and then demanded his
ex-wife and her attorney
also get sanity tests.
Mr. Ostrom insisted he was
neither violent, nor crazy,
and had no intention of hurting anyone.
Rather, he was simply frustrated
with what he believed was a system
stacked against men in custody disputes
with financial support
and wanted to draw attention to the issue.
Now trial by combat
is technically illegal
in almost every state.
And in fact, in Kentucky of all places,
there is an anti trial by combat law
that says every elected official
who takes the oath of office
must actually swear before God
that they never fought in
a dual with deadly weapons
nor challenged or aided any in such fight.
Now #notlegaladvice,
regardless of the legality
of trial by combat,
it's probably a bad idea
to settle disputes with deadly weapons,
especially if you wanna
get elected in Kentucky.
- Nor have I sent nor accepted a challenge
to fight a dual with deadly weapons.
- [Devin] But that takes us to perhaps
the most bitter divorce
filing of all time.
And as you just saw,
emotions can run high
in matters of the heart.
That's why for divorces,
it's often a good idea to hire an attorney
to proceed with an air of professionalism.
Or you could just choose the path
of Texas attorney Paul Frank Hensler,
who handled his own divorce
with a handwritten petition
that was um...
Well, it was interesting.
Let's just take a look at this.
Now fair warning,
this is a 1985 divorce
petition from Texas,
so don't be surprised from what follows,
where it's not exactly the
most evolved of pleadings.
And in what reads like a
badly written country song,
or honestly an awesome country song,
Hensler states his wife
moved outta the house
after only 10 months of holy matrimony
after she got pissed off and hauled ass
with their car, the
MasterCard, her $365 in cash,
her federal civil rights
nine year old employment
discrimination case
against the Texas Department
of Human Resources
to which she is welcome,
having board me stiff for two years
about just how everybody picks on her.
So Hensler declares that
the marriage has become very unsupportable
due to a conflict of personalities
between he and his wife,
but says the real blame
lies with his ex-wife's
failure to provide the quote
"legitimate ends of the marriage
that prevents any reasonable
expectation of reconciliation,
unless she consents to having
her mouth surgically closed."
My God, man.
Holy cow, you put this
in front of the court.
Now Hensler attests that he and his wife
had no children together, although quote,
"Petitioner swears on oath
he did everything he
could to knock her up."
That's not even germaine
to the pleading here.
But Hensler sarcastically
says his wife is quote,
"Liberated now and feminists
don't have children
by male chauvinist pig
lawyers, so she swears."
Gosh, I can't believe this
marriage only lasted 10 months.
Now Hensler requests the
court divide their estate
among parties based on possession,
clarifying he means the
legal sense of possession,
not possession like in horror movies.
But Hensler does assert his
wife could easily stand in
for quote, "The girl from the Exorcist."
- I'm the holy spirit.
(girl growls)
- Hensler requests the
court grant his divorce
and have his wife's name legally changed
to the demonic Bella Abzug, Jr.,
a play on the name Beelzebub.
Hensler then closes the
petition with quote,
"Screw you (beep),"
while signing the pleading with
"Respectfully submitted, Paul F. Hensler".
Fun fact, lawyers who sign
things "respectfully,"
nine times outta 10
were secretly meaning no respect intended.
Except me, of course.
Always with due respect.
#notalllawyers.
But that brings us to the defense attorney
who demanded that everyone
call him Captain Justice.
Now to promote the fair
administration of justice,
courts serve as evidentiary gatekeepers
to ensure only reliable
and authenticated evidence
is admitted at trial,
while excluding any evidence
that needlessly inflames,
confuses, or prejudices the trier of fact.
But in one Tennessee burglary case,
the dueling efforts of
prosecutors and defense counsel
to obtain a fair trial took a very bizarre
and let's call it a humorous turn.
Now, back in 2013, the state of Tennessee
was scheduled to prosecute Donald Powell
for aggravated burglary.
Assistant District Attorney
General Tammy Rettig
was the local prosecutor
who represented the state,
while Powell was represented by
inappropriately named Drew Justice.
Before trial, ADA Rettig
filed a motion in limine
to get the court to exclude evidence
she believed would unfairly
prejudice the state's case.
Her request stopped defense counsel
from referring to the
state's legal representative
as "the Government", because
that's not very nice.
Yes, that's right.
The prosecutor, who represented
the government of Tennessee,
demanded that the defense
counsel be prohibited
from calling her "the Government"
because it might bias the jury
against, let me see here...
The government.
(book slams)
Now in ADA Rettig's one page motion,
she suggested Mr. Justice's
repeated references
to the state's attorney
as "the Government"
was derogatory and prejudicial
to the state's case
and Mr. Justice should instead refer
to the state's attorneys
by their names or titles.
Mr. Justice responded
to this baffling motion
with his own appropriately
cheeky response.
"The government has moved to
ban the word government.,"
Mr. Justice begins,
noting that the state of Tennessee quote,
"Offers precisely zero legal authority
for this rather nitpicky position."
Mr. Justice argues granting such a motion
would violate his first amendment rights.
Mr. Justice asserts that
the term "the Government"
is not inherently derogatory,
particularly since courts frequently refer
to the prosecutor's office
as "the Government."
In the alternative, Mr. Justice argues
that if the ADA gets
to choose her own name,
then we the defense should
get to choose our own names as well.
Mr. Justice first requested the court
stop referring to the
defendant as defendant,
stating that the word has a
negative connotation that quote,
"Dehumanizes Mr. Donald Powell."
Mr. Justice instead proposed
calling his defendant
by his full name, Mr.
Donald Powell, quote,
"The citizen accused"
or "That innocent man."
But Mr. Justice was not yet finished.
He asked the court that he
no longer be referred to
by the meager name of lawyer or attorney.
That's when Drew Justice
went full Ted Mosby.
- Pleased to meet you captain.
I'm Galactic President
Superstar McAwesomeville.
- [Devin] First, Mr. Justice
suggested that the court
call him "Defender of the Innocent,"
as all defendants are presumed
innocent until proven guilty.
He then proposed the title
of "Guardian of the Realm."
Mr. Justice also suggested if
ADA Rettig gets to be quote,
"Assistant District Attorney General,"
then defense counsel
deserves an appropriate
military title to match,
"Captain Justice."
Mr. Justice, sorry,
Captain Justice argued that
the court shouldn't even
be calling him the defense,
writing the quote, "whole
idea of being defensive
comes across to most
people as suspicious."
The captain then proposed that his side
instead be dubbed "The resistance."
And as a "Star Wars" fan,
I can certainly see the
appeal of that last one.
But the cheeky defense
counsel closed his motion
with a similarly rye fashion, quote,
"Wherefore Captain Justice,
Guardian of the Realm,
and Leader of the Resistance,
primarily asks that the
court deny the state's motion
as lacking legal basis.
Alternatively, the Citizen Accused
moves for an order in limine
modifying the speech
code as aforementioned,
and requiring all other
euphemisms and feel-good terms
as the court finds appropriate."
Now you might have thought
that lawyers are incapable
of committing extensive trolling in court,
but this motion shows
just how wrong you are.
Yeah, sometimes when the
prosecution does ridiculous things,
you gotta just troll the crap out of him.
Now sadly, the court denied
the Assistant District
Attorney General's motion,
while also denying
defense counsel's request
to be called Captain Justice.
Tennessee's fears that being
called "the Government"
would prejudice their case
turned out to be unfounded.
After waiving his right to a jury trial,
Mr. Powell was, in fact,
convicted of attempted aggravated burglary
and his conviction was upheld on appeal.
But it seems like Mr. Justice's suggestion
that his client be called
quote, "That Innocent Man"
was just a little bit premature,
if not incredibly petty trolling.
So A+ on that.
But that takes us to an
actual meritorious motion
because one of the best
reasons, if not the best reason,
to ask for a continuance
is that the Chiefs made
it to the Super Bowl, man.
Now of the many skills
that lawyers possess,
one we certainly lack is the
ability to see the future.
But one possible exception is DUI attorney
and Kansas City Chiefs
super fan Denise Kirby,
who successfully predicted
in a legal filing
that the Chiefs would break a
50 year championship drought
that would render her too busy
cheering on her team at Super
Bowl 54 to attend trial.
Here's how it went down.
Now in October 2019,
Ms. Kirby filed a motion
to continue her February
3rd, 2020 DUI trial
on the grounds that she'd
personally be in Miami
watching her team play in Super Bowl 54.
At the time of the motion,
the concept was laughable.
So much so, that apparently
everyone in the courtroom
laughed at her request.
But then the Chiefs made
it to the Super Bowl.
So Ms. Kirby filed a new
motion to continue trial.
According to Ms. Kirby's motion, quote,
"The courtroom erupted in laughter"
when she confidently asserted in October
that she would be in Miami
to watch the Chiefs in the Super Bowl."
She further noted that
the court had advised
that should that happen, it
would grant the continuance.
Quote, "It happened," wrote Ms. Kirby.
As a result, Ms. Kirby would
not be back in time for trial
and thus needed a continuance.
The motion ends with quote, "Go Chiefs!"
Because of course it does.
Now ultimately the Chiefs and Ms. Kirby
would have the last laugh.
In a historic fourth quarter comeback,
the Chiefs overcame a 10 point deficit
with 21 unanswered points
to beat the San Francisco 49ers 31 to 20.
It was heartbreaking.
I was born in San Francisco.
I'm a big 49ers fan.
Sorry.
The court, having granted
Ms. Kirby's continuance,
helped fulfill the prophecy
that allowed her to see
that historic victory.
And that takes us to the
importance of being earnest.
Hemingway.
Now lawyers have a reputation
for being humorless,
buttoned-up suits.
- Well, I'm a professional.
I'm serious and I'm a professional.
- Can't imagine why.
But we lawyer-types love to
cut loose and have some fun.
So what is an attorney to do
when our extracurricular
activities clash with trial dates?
Well, if you are Florida
lawyer, Frank Louderback,
getting ready to attend
an Ernest Hemingway Look-Alike Contest,
you hope that your court is understanding
of your scheduling conflict
and non-refundable deposits, as well.
The court was not.
Here's what happened.
In 2012, Florida man Jerry Allen Bottorff
was facing federal charges
in connection with a murder-for-hire plot
involving the murder victim's wife,
Cristie Sehorne-Bottorff,
whom Jerry had met at a swinger's club,
and who later became Jerry's wife.
Just your typical Florida love story.
Now, Frank Louderback was scheduled
to go to trial in July of 2012,
but everything changed for
the St. Petersburg lawyer
when he became a semi-finalist
in the annual Ernest Hemingway
Look-Alike Competition
at Sloppy Joe's Bar in Key West.
Now Louderback understandably felt
that this fortuitous
change in circumstances
merited a brief suspension of trial,
informing the court quote,
"Undersigned counsel has
secured a block of six rooms
to accommodate family, friends and fans
and has had to pay
non-refundable deposits."
Now non-refundable
deposits not withstanding,
US District Court Judge Steven D. Merryday
denied the request writing quote,
"Between a murder-for-hire trial
and an annual look-alike contest,
surely Hemingway, a perfervid admirer
of quote 'grace under pressure'
would choose the trial."
And in his denial,
Judge Merryday showcased
his own sense of humor
and admiration for Hemingway,
citing Dorothy Parker's
1929 New Yorker profile
of the author, quote,
"At his most robust,
Hemingway exemplified the
intrepid defense lawyer.
He works like hell and through it.
He has the most profound bravery.
He has had pain and the kind of poverty
that you don't believe.
He has had about eight times
the normal allotment of responsibilities.
And he has never once compromised.
He has never turned off on an easier path
than the one he staked himself.
It takes courage."
Judge Merryday closes the motion
by citing the iconic final line
of Hemingway's "The Sun Also Rises."
And you've gotta love the way
that the judge ends this order.
Best of luck to counsel
in next year's contest.
The motion docket 127 is denied.
And while Louderback would
live to compete another day,
sadly Bottorff and his wife
pleaded guilty to the charges
and were sentenced to life in prison
and in perhaps the greatest
miscarriage of justice,
would never live to see a
Hemingway look-alike contest.
Of course, none of these lawyers
pleadings make any sense.
They are completely illogical.
They could really use a logic
or math course from Brilliant.
Today's sponsor, Brilliant
is an online learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on, interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious learners,
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
One of my favorite courses
is All About Logic.
Brilliant's logic courses covers
liar and truth teller
riddles, logical fallacies,
machine logic, and even
some strategic game theory.
Logic is, of course,
a crucial skill that
lawyers need every day.
Not the ones that we
covered in this video,
but at least lawyers,
generally speaking nonetheless.
And Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
Within Brilliant's library,
you'll find courses and topics
like calculus, linear algebra and math.
That applies to trading and finance.
You'll also find courses
on gravitational physics,
astronomy, and machine learning.
And you can level up in
just five minutes a day
by working on the daily challenge.
Each daily challenge provides you
with the context and
framework that you need
so you don't have to take a
deep dive if you don't want to.
You can sign up and start
learning for free today
at brilliant.org/legaleagle
Or you can click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description.
The first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel
or click on this link over here
with all of my other legal videos.
So click on screen or
I'll see you in court.